what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is a channel
where i help you break into data science
and grow your skills in the field
so this is another video in my r
tutorial series
in the last few videos i did over r we
covered
using the carrot package to do machine
learning it was a four part series
and i highly recommend watching that
series before watching this one
well carrot is not the only package that
you can use in r for machine learning
purposes
there's this whole framework of packages
known as tidy models
and that's what we're going to cover in
this series now the reason i recommend
watching my carrot videos
first is because at least at the time
i'm recording this video which is
march of 2021 carrot is a little bit
more mature
it has a lot more fully developed
capabilities
and some of the packages in the tidy
model suite
they're at pretty early versions
that is they're at versions like point
one or point two
whereas carrot it's a lot more fully
developed
i fully expect a lot of just future r
development for machine learning to take
place
under the tidy models ecosystem so a
year or two from now
tidy models could be a much bigger thing
than it is now
but just for now for the most part i'm
gonna try to structure this tutorial
to be as accessible as possible but
there are some instances where i'm gonna
point to
this is covered in a little bit greater
detail in the carrot videos
so before we get started take a moment
to smash the like button for the youtube
algorithm and subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already
and then if you guys would be willing to
support my channel i will have links in
the description of the video to things
like my paypal address
my patreon account and my crypto wallet
addresses
and then as usual this script will be
available on my github repo which is
also in the description of the video
now without further ado let's get
started alright so the first thing that
you're going to notice
is i'm calling more packages here than i
usually do
now the first thing that you have to
understand about tidy models
is that it's an ecosystem of packages so
kind of like with the tidy verse
with tidy verse you have packages like
dplyr for data manipulation
ggplot2 for visualization all those
packages
are part of the tidyverse and when i
call the tidyverse
all of those packages are automatically
loaded in
that's generally the case with tidy
models too
now there are some more new packages
like themis or stacks
which you for now have to call
separately
uh but just think of it very analogously
to tidy verse
to where if you call the tidy models
package many of your dependencies are
going to come in
now if you've seen the carrot tutorial
you remember that i worked through a
full
example for the german credit data set
the only reason that i'm going to call
the carat package here
is just to load in that german credit
data
now towards later in this video you're
going to see where
uh some of these more individual machine
learning packages like random forest or
kknn for k-nearest neighbors are going
to come into play
now there's a number of sources from
which this tutorial draws influence and
structure
those will as usual be linked in the
description those represent fantastic
supplemental reading above and beyond
this tutorial series
but the overall list of packages which
make up tidy models that we're going to
make use of in this tutorial series
are listed here we're going to go
through each of these individually in
their own section
but you see that each of these packages
serve a different purpose within
the entire machine learning pipeline so
in a machine learning problem
you typically will have to start off by
partitioning your data into testing and
training
functions from the r sample package are
going to help us to do that
now our sample in and of itself does not
have a ton of functions
but the functions from that package are
going to help us with this task
so on and so forth for the recipes
package that's where we're going to do
things like pre-process
pre-processing our data before we train
models
parsnip when we actually train the
models
so on and so forth now if you've seen
the carrot tutorial
you know that i start with the german
credit data set
and there's a little bit of just overall
pre-processing that i want to do to that
data set up front
the data set is a little bit cleaner
than what you would typically expect
from real world data
so i just do some completely tangential
stuff in order to
do things like simulate uh some missing
data
that and just turn these things into
factors when they're
when that's clearly the appropriate data
type
for those variables then just you know
call a summary of the data set up front
to get a feel for what that looks
like so if you haven't seen the tutorial
series on carrot
i'm just very briefly going to go over
some things you need to be aware of with
this data
first of all the response variable here
is class
this essentially indicates for every
individual subject
do we expect them to be a good credit
bet or a bad credit bet
you'll see it's got a 70 30 balance here
700 out of 1000 subjects are
good credit bets 300 out of 1000 are bad
so we've got a classification problem so
we have a few continuous variables over
here
but you have some of these factor
variables like number existing credits
where you have levels that simply don't
show up a lot
like point six percent of subjects have
four existing credits or more
so you have a little bit of a variance
imbalance there
but even going beyond that you see some
of these variables like take
telephone uh yes or no here foreign
worker
yes or no or one versus zero but then
you have these other variables here
which are in dummy form
meaning every level of this housing
variable here
gets its own column so rent
own and for free are different levels of
this housing variable
you'll see that 0.179 plus 0.713
plus 0.108 well that all adds up to 1
because again they're
just different levels of one variable so
you see that these factors are just
coded in different ways
and we need these things to be
consistent in order to have a robust
machine learning classifier now we're
going to use various tidy models
functions
in order to in order to fix this up but
i will say the first thing that we're
going to do just
up front is collapse this variable
number
existing credits so instead of having
four levels
one two three and four because three and
four
occur with pretty uh low frequency
all we're going to do is collapse uh to
one
versus two three and four all get their
own category
so i'm kind of doing that on a pretty
arbitrary basis but
that's just how i'm choosing to tackle
this problem alright so the very first
package from tidy models that we're
going to make use of here
is the r sample package i already
spoiled at the beginning of this video
what it's going to be used for
but it's in order to split our data into
training and testing sets
yes granted there are other functions in
our sample and we're going to see an
example of one of them later
but that's the number one thing that
you're going to use this package for
now if you're unfamiliar with the
broader machine learning framework
the reason we do this is we want to
train our classifier
on a training set but then we want to
evaluate at the
performance of that classifier on a
testing set
which consists of data that classifier
has not yet
seen okay now if you've seen my caret
tutorial
this is going to look pretty similar to
the create date
data partition function from caret
what we're basically going to do is we
create that initial split
using this initial split function so
this p or prop argument here specifies
what proportion of the data we want to
use for training purposes
anything from like 60 to 80 percent is
pretty common here
i'm just going to use 70 of the data for
training
the remaining 30 is for testing
and i want to do this uh splitting
proportionally with respect
to the class variable again that's our
response variable
we want that same 70 30 split that
exists with that class variable
to exist for the training set and for
the testing set
okay so all we do is create that initial
split
then we can use the training and testing
functions
to extract the training set and the
testing set
from that split object that we created
okay so let's just create a summary of
the training set to make sure that we
did this correctly and we see that we
have 700 rows to the training data
that's what we expect because
70 of our initial 1000 uh subjects
should be used for training but then
remember that our split for the class
variable
is also 70 30. if you look here
we have 490 out of 700
that's 70 percent are expected to have
a good credit and 210 are in the bad
class
so uh this passes every test so far this
is looking good
that about covers what you need to know
for now from the our sample package
the next one we're gonna go through is
the recipes package
so most of the steps and functionality
that goes into
pre-processing a data set to get it into
an appropriate format for training a
machine learning classifier
most of those steps are going to come
from the recipes package
so some of the key steps that i like to
use here are
step k n n impute that's going to
impute missing data using the k n n
algorithm or k
nearest neighbors step dummy that's
going to get all of our
factor variables into a consistent
format so remember with our housing
variable
where each level of that variable got
its own column
well we want all the factor variables in
our data to be in that
format for machine learning purposes
anyway
so that's where step dummy is going to
come in
step nzv is going to get rid of
variables with near zero variance
and then we have step range over here
that's basically for normalizing our
variables
so that the variables fall within a
range from 0 to 1.
some algorithms they get tripped up if
you have variables with
radically different ranges neural
networks being an example
that's not the case with all algorithms
but with enough of them
having variables with different ranges
presents enough of a problem to where
just getting in the habit of normalizing
variables
uh will tend to save you some headaches
note that that's different from
standardizing variables which is from
converting them
to z scores so actually step
normalize if you use that function that
will help you
standardize the variables but what we
typically refer to as normalizing
that is converting to a zero one scale
doesn't come from step normalize
it comes from the step range function so
uh
that may be one thing that can trip you
up or confuse you at first but
just as long as you get used to the
syntax you're good to go
now there are some super useful uh
helper functions which are gonna make
our life easy here
so for instance all predictors that's
pretty self-explanatory
we are going to start up front actually
uh by defining
a uh formula and
what data set that we're using so class
is our response variable
we use this format or the syntax here to
indicate that
all the other variables in our in our
data set are
predictors we're using the training set
here
and so when we use all predictors
we're just telling this recipe here that
we want to use the k
n n algorithm for imputing missing data
for all predictors
we're going to use this uh step dummy
approach for all nominal variables or
all of our factor variables
but not all of our outcomes because
remember our
outcome variable here is also a factor
variable
the class variable has two levels to it
but we don't want to use that dummy
approach for our response variable
so a similar thing for the step nzv
and for step range for step range we're
going to specify
a minimum equals zero and maximum equals
one
so think of this completely uh to like
a recipe that you might use for making
dinner so
you look at the steps to the recipe uh
you've got your step one step two step
three step four or whatever
so you prepare that recipe so you have
all your ingredients up front
and you know what's what order that
you're going to do various things in
and then you uh basically conduct that
recipe right
it's kind of analogous here with our
syntax here
where we start with this recipe object
that we defined up here
a credit recipe then we prep that on the
training set
and then we bake it so it's a little bit
weird because we have two functions for
this
but we're just going to prepare all the
steps and then apply them
and then we using this bake function
once we do that
we're going to get these new uh data
sets here
for which all these steps have been
applied
now you just saw me do this for both the
training set and the testing set
we applied all the exact same steps for
the two different data sets
so that's a lot cleaner than doing
something similar
in in carrot one thing i will say
compared to carrots that's
not necessarily easy is recursive
feature elimination
so you saw in the carrot tutorial
there's
the rfe uh set of functions
in order for eliminating variables that
just are useless or not informative
that's not to say that they're near zero
or actually have zero variance they're
just
useless variables that don't help us
perform better for training a machine
learning algorithm
now that procedure is pretty
straightforward and the functionalities
all developed in carrot
but it's not developed yet in tidy
models at least at the time that i'm
recording this video
so max khan and he was one of the
biggest
individuals who's worked on the tidy
model suite of packages
he's come up with a custom solution in
order to do this
and i'm going to have it linked here but
it's not
super clean or straightforward now
even in the carrot tutorial i showed you
how to do it but i didn't necessarily do
it
so if you want to learn how to do it the
link is going to be provided here in
order to do it
the parsnip package is where the fun
really starts to begin
and that's where for the first time
we're going to start actually
training and fitting our machine
learning classifiers
so the first thing that we have to do is
actually specify the models
and how these things are actually coming
about
and now the syntax for this gets a
little bit
uh weird so i'm going to explain how all
this comes together
now for the most part every individual
method
is going to have its own function now
i want to train a logistic regression
as well as a random forest so the
logistic regression gets its own
function
up here logistic reg random forest gets
its own function
that's rand forest okay so
you can either then using the pipe
function pipe to
set mode or you can specify the mode
just as an argument to this parent
function here
but we need to also specify is this a
regression case or a classification case
this is a classification scenario
because
uh our outcome variable here is discrete
it's not continuous
so this is a classification problem then
the next thing that we have to do is set
the engine
now actually if we move on to the random
forest uh
what the engine is is going to make a
little bit more sense
so there are multiple different packages
which can be used for random forest
implementations
random forest is an example of a package
which can be used to
create random forests the ranger package
is another
package which can be used for random
forests and so
if you use those different packages you
are probably going to end up with
different results
and so that specification is going to
come from the set
engine function here now if it looks
like the syntax
just gets a like a little bit of looking
stuff up like okay if you want to try a
different method you have to look the
syntax up
here's a shortcut which is going to make
your life a lot easier
if you go up here to add-ins go down
here to generate parsnip model
specifications
give it a second here and then over here
there's this ui which is going to pop up
which is going to basically
help you write the specification code
for you
so you're going to specify what type of
model do you want is it classification
or regression
then over here is a list of the of all
the different methods
okay so for example bag mars that would
be an implementation of
multivariate adaptive regression splines
that comes from the earth
engine or the earth package and so if
you do this
there's no need to memorize all this
stuff so
that could make your life significantly
so we can in the next step go on to
actually
fit these models that we've now
specified
all that we need to do is specify the
model object
the formula and then the data set that
we're using
that we're fitting these to the training
data now we have our fit objects
we can go in and look at what the output
looks like
for the uh logistic regression it's
pretty
straightforward typical logistic
regression output
pretty similar kind of thing for the
random forest
okay so that's where i'm going to leave
you
in the next video or videos here we're
going to move into actually evaluating
the performance and seeing how we did on
the testing set
and then going a little bit deeper into
things like down sampling and up
sampling
as far as pre-processing the data to
deal with class imbalance and then going
a little bit deeper into actually tuning
our hyper parameters so thanks for
watching this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data